hey 42 here history is full of
horrifying events some of which are
truly more terrifying than any fictional
story here's some true stories from
history that will chill you to the bone
the Italian Renaissance was a period in
Italy's history of outstanding art and
culture this 200 year period gave birth
to some of the greatest artists and
artworks humanity has ever known such as
Leonardo da Vinci and Michelangelo but
it also gave birth to something
considerably more gruesome a plague of
real-life zombies in 1494 was the first
major outbreak of syphilis before
antibiotics were invented syphilis was a
fatal infection something to be gravely
feared the disease slowly ate away at
the victims face causing their flesh to
fall away resulting in the complete
destruction of their face and genitals
within just a few months and death would
surely follow shortly afterwards during
this period it was not uncommon to see
Frenchmen and Italians walking around
with half of their face falling off and
their bare skulls exposed just like a
scene from a horrific zombie movie thank
God for modern medicine Henry Howard
Holmes better known as hate-hate Holmes
is widely known as one of America's
first serial killers his body count is
thought to be somewhere between 27 and
200 he achieved this by building a hotel
in a bustling part of Chicago in the
1890s and designed it to be the perfect
killing arena to fulfill his sick
desires it later came to be known
murder castle hey cake Holmes
meticulously design the hotel to be a
complex maze of windowless rooms he even
hired a handful of different builders to
construct a hotel in sections so only
Holmes would know the layout making
escape virtually impossible for his
victims every inch of the hotel was
designed to confuse and terrify his
victims including doors that only opened
from the outside doorways that opened
onto brick walls and they're safe big
enough to put a person inside to slowly
suffocate them undershoot that allowed
Holmes to dump bodies from the upper
floors to the basement where two massive
furnaces and a large supply of flesh
dripping gas 'add was stored the Roman
city of Pompeii was once one of the
greatest civilizations on earth
unfortunately it is most famously known
for the disaster that occurred there in
79 AD when Italy's Mount Vesuvius
erupted wiping out Pompeii and burying
it in ash for over a millennium but even
worse affected by the eruption was
Pompey's neighboring city Herculaneum
just like Pompeii Herculaneum was also
spectacularly and horrific Lee buried in
volcanic ash but Herculaneum suffered a
fate much worse than its more famous
neighbor Herculaneum was also hit by a
superheated pyroclastic flow which is a
fast-moving current of hot gas and rock
spewed out from a volcano that reaches
speeds of 450 miles per hour but the
most deadly thing about this volcanic
death cloud is that it can reach
temperatures of up to a thousand degrees
Celsius its incredible speed meant the
whole city would have been engulfed by a
1000 degree cloud of gas in just seconds
this caused what must have been one of
the most horrific sites in history the
human skull is full of liquids and if
you heat it up super quickly it explodes
this is exactly what happened at
Herculaneum in 79 AD the 1000 degree
volcanic cloud caused people's skin to
vaporize their brains to boil and their
skulls to literally explode all in under
a second which sounds like a very good
reason not to live next to an active
volcano although this doesn't seem to
have got through to the residents of
Naples
during World War two countless
atrocities happened to humans but
animals received their share of
suffering
- in 1939 during the run-up to World War
two the British government formed the
National air raid precautions animals
committee the purpose of the committee
was to decide what people should do with
their pets
once war broke out the biggest concern
was that food shortages would have been
made even worse due to people feeding
their pets so to solve the problem the
British government sent out pamphlets
called
advice to animal owners it featured an
advertisement for a specific type of gun
which was best suited to killing animals
and guidelines on how to humanely
dispose of your pet within a week of the
campaign being launched 750,000 pets
across the British Isles had been killed
by their owners or taken to
purpose-built pet disposal centers it
has since come to be known as the pet
Holocaust one of the most horrific
stories from all of history was the
Nanking Massacre during the second
sino-japanese war in 1947 the Japanese
Tyrael army captured the Chinese city of
Nanking which was then the Chinese
capital over a period of six weeks an
estimated 300,000 on armed Chinese
civilians were slaughtered by the
Imperial Japanese army but it gets worse
the horrific event is also widely known
as The Rape of Nanking because the
Japanese forces raped and looted most of
the city's residents before killing them
the Japanese soldiers even raped infants
and the elderly as well as forcing
citizens to commit incestuous acts and
many other atrocities on their fellow
Chinese citizens ever since the massacre
an attempt to maintain their pride
Japanese officials have outright denied
that the event ever happened claiming it
was a complete fabrication and then
attempt at anti-japanese propaganda
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
you